this is the true story of one tech
addicted journalist who moved into a
motorhome for 24 hours
to find out through a series of
challenges that 5g could power all of
our home devices
at warrants all right
come on in back here we've got
my living room bedroom and
so many gadgets alright so this isn't
really a reality tv
show now let's talk about what's
happening here in this 5g rv
trademark pending see that poll that's a
verizon 5g small cell
and inside the rb is a verizon oneplus 8
5g smartphone it's getting crazy fast
speeds from the tower
10 times faster than my home wifi in
fact
also inside the rv 15 other gadgets that
are being powered by 5g
via the phone's hotspot feature yes
all of those are getting 5g connectivity
so why the heck did i do this well see i
live here in jersey city
which is just being lit up with 5g
service from all the major u.s carriers
but the fastest type of 5g called
millimeter wave
requires that you be within a few
hundred feet from the cell site to get
top speeds
and you guessed it my real home not next
to a pole yet
yes the speeds are insanely fast but on
a smartphone
they're not really that helpful i mean
how often do you need to download
five movies in five minutes where i
really need these speeds are at home
where i have multiple connected devices
and multiple family members using them
so that's what i'm trying to test in
here in a series of daunting home
bandwidth challenges
this is a wall but within a moveable
home
and this in here is the bathroom with
full 5g
service but before the challenges you
have to understand the complicated world
of 5g buckle up
there are two types of 5g in the us at
the moment millimeter wave 5g
named for its high frequency waveforms
is insanely
fast at least six times faster than 4g
in my tests
and 10 times faster than my home wifi
but the coverage is very limited
you need to be within a few hundred feet
or so of a cell site to get the signal
and the speed it doesn't penetrate walls
or other obstacles very well
verizon att and t-mobile are putting up
millimeter wave cells throughout the
country
by this one i got 1300 megabits per
second download speeds on verizon's
network
on my home wi-fi i get 100 megabits per
second
that 5g speed is bonkers then there's
sub 6 named for a set of frequencies
below
6 gigahertz it's not as fast as
millimeter wave but it was faster than
4g lte in my tests
and it's more practical because it works
inside buildings and the coverage is
more widespread
for now only at t and t-mobile have
sub-sticks
including here in jersey city verizon
says it plans to roll out its sub-six
network before the end of the year in
the u.s
in downtown jersey city att's sub-six
coverage averaged
megabits per second and t-mobile's sub 6
got 120 megabits per second
still pretty good at least when i could
find strong 5g signal strength
regardless of carrier you need a new 5g
phone to get these speeds
ok on to the challenges
challenge 1 video streaming to simulate
my home i fired up frozen 2 on the tv
2 4k video streams on these laptops a
facetime call to my mom
whatsoever you look great and of course
for security i
installed a connected doorbell on all
three networks the streams were good
and the video call was clear to really
up the 5g stakes i added in a call to my
dad and placed another video call to my
colleagues
how do i look now no you look very clear
this test was hit or miss it was hard to
tell what issues were caused by the
network or the phone's hot spots
you can't see me these really aren't
meant to connect 10 devices at a time
plus some of the carrier's plans have
data caps on hotspot usage
and slow down speeds once you exceed it
challenge two
gaming i don't know a ton about gaming
yeah boom
is that good it's your teammate no i get
a puncher
so i made my producer kenny a world
renowned gamer
just kidding he only plays on the
weekends jump in and start playing apex
legends
first on verizon's millimeter wave
network i know
i'm a horrible boss listen i was
impressed the game played better than it
did on my wired home broadband
connection
by a long shot there's no rubber banding
where you lag warp from one place to
another
and no lag icons finally we can game in
the bush
i was similarly impressed with the
graphics and speed on the oculus quest
vr headset
menus loaded super fast large games
downloaded within minutes and i
attended a live in-person vr event
even while kenny was playing on the xbox
on the same network
verizon's network held strong t-mobile's
5g performed similarly but att's was
shaky
don't blame the internet and kenny
complained the game was laggy even when
we tried to move to a better location
challenge three uploading uploading a
one gigabyte folder to google drive took
six to seven minutes on each 5g network
on my home wifi
it took four and a half minutes the most
i was able to notch was about 60
megabits on the upload on verizon
my home network has a hundred megabits
per second on upload speeds so what did
we learn here today we learned that 5g
is very very fast and a lot more useful
when you can connect multiple gadgets to
that network than just say
a single phone of course this isn't the
intended use of 5g yet and it will take
time for the carriers to improve
coverage
and release home routers and hotspots
for this type of use
verizon already has a 5g home offering
in some markets
and t-mobile is gearing up to do the
same of course you'll probably end up
paying
more for it all too but for now if i
owned an rv
i'd put out my family vacations one 5g
pole at a time okay this was fun but i
miss my family
and i would like to go home
you